welcome to this video playing h no a GF
what the heck is this that there's no
vegan defense right the sky or the name
DAP nope yeah Knight c3 a place d5 I
think okay that's probably good for
white but I I really have no idea that
what what's going on that is
compensation bow Queen a5 is the pointer
okay maybe I'm just developing I don't
think that this opening is so terrible
and it is it's probably not really great
but it's nothing that you can complete
the review probably if you just place
Knight f6 back I mean you really don't
don't know what this what the effect was
not age five but it's it's not really
really losing or anything just lose this
time the chakra pathogen that was not
why no draw see no particular reason
their wife let's see what he's doing
ideas sc5 trying to expand um yeah still
see five I guess one what happens if i
attack the night but I don't have
anything great okay let's go see 5 f-5
95 maybe I thought 95 but he has f4f 496
it's not really working for him and I
think maybe you can play 92 f 6 now then
he runs into the forks they're not
possible hmm so what does he play F 496
Queen somewhere 9 f8 should win the
exchange
yeah not sure what is movies yeah okay
96 and i will take a fade it's still
it's still a bit murky but hard to
believe step better move no I think I
should take takes there is the question
is to take age 5 or not take edge
five-and-a-half 95 I play 95 queen to g5
maybe a possible counter-attacks okay I
think I'm just going back if he goes you
know if he does that I have not you form
which cannot be not sure though if I
really want to go there I can also take
h5 yeah I don't know the night doesn't
doesn't really look like a huge threat
there may be threatening night I'm okay
and I'd be five I thought was something
more serious
so just this for possible Bishop c5 on
Bishop c5 96 is also move and start with
that and then 9696 now a four-night f7
should be should be quite annoying and
also f5 maybe I can just take okay I
cannot grab a two should see 495 should
win material ok and here I also queen
bee three as possible but not sure how
good it is I can I think that's just
just straight stuff here and bishops in
40 km can check that on c5
I could Queen d6 maybe take stakes 94
yeah I can and attack the queenside then
not show him what what's best 94 I
thought queen is seven attacking be
seven and things like that should be ok
I was also thinking 27 but then night c5
is probably coming maybe b6 is a move
here actually Fisher bear three maybe oh
that's surprising what is he doing now
Bishop chicks I don't get it 92 92 I'll
take b7 yeah of course I'm gladly
returning this exchange if I get this
this passer on the C file maybe i can
after night everyone i can take the rook
simply yeah i can actually quincy one is
made with Queen yet
now it's back rank and some quite
helpful 55 I guess huh yeah it must be
should be good so just okay I know no
it's not so clear Quincy one and if i
take on f1 what is he doing then time
morning rook c8 old and maybe
still dominating on the light squares
but of course that was not planned
beforehand check okay got that one don't
want to trade Queens with this weekend
King position
still tricky check check the points
there should be a bit too much to hold
check check check
check check I could have played sadly
this this is perform
okay black forfeits Bishop c4 and I will
promote him boy I was still sort
somewhat tricky Jeff really allowed a
little bit too much they're like this TX
takes Bishop Pucci eight yeah okay I
really underestimated night takes
everyone down I should just move the
room and and continue from there just
being the material up plus six or
something yeah well this is this is of
course good stir because I get the pawn
but check it was far far less than what
I what I thought I'd get jaw tricky
let's have a look there at this phase
outside right round right after the
opening I mean yeah 95 looks like a
problem I have a computer just wants to
play Queenie a dance as it's still quite
okay okay but this should lead to an
advantage right my cheeks take stakes
yeah if the comp wants to grab their
cadets possible but I wasn't sure if
it's a good idea to take this outside
this off side piece but it's probably
really good yeah I have this and
possibly bishops III m okay then that is
that is even even simpler then what I
would I did ok let's to have won this
game after the recent slump thanks for
watching